I believe mr. X didn't even flinch from
me use this against him
like what lots of big grenade at him and
he does not even feel it oh yeah okay
guys it's my ancestor Fox oh by the way
I'm intending on them recording I'm very
late to the game but recording a like
reacting to your assumptions of me
videos so I've put it on Instagram I
mean you can reply to me there with your
assumptions of me you know any
assumptions like I don't know I don't
wash my face
any symptoms you might have like I'm bad
cooking because I am Jasmine's bag was
this card read
oh yes I'm going
okay and it was hot
[Music]
then okay him just knock them out of the
way okay hello it's not exactly mr. off
the bat so I'm not going you to the gun
shop no no gun shot for me no no no what
other way is there to go then what are
you on about or maybe on this side of
the street
[Music]
zombies they knew they showed me the way
over wrong yeah I know I mean I know
that now now that you're going there I
don't think a certain way so we can be
quiet last time we learned that shooting
them with their legs is a lot more
beneficial than trying to get a head
shot
why is then easy that makes me want a
Tron light I just want to stay here
where it's safe
no dots no doggies
does it go in building
No
meet reading dumb can I get up yet no
I'm not even gonna try
thank you look at that idiot
oh my god look at the 90s looks like a
bag you were no idea
I always underestimate this game
[Music]
girl zigzag zigzag way true
rummy works every time works like a
charm
why do they move and try to shoot thing
hang on sherry Jackson Jack in this game
dogs will attack you no matter what
there's no way around them you might as
well just like run orbit see try and
shoot them the Eliquis definitely do not
run
do not run around liquors just makes
your whole situation ten times worse do
not
but you're so glad you have a submachine
gun hell yes I am hello I have the
pendants he did though if we're in the
right timeframe where did he die
it wasn't here wasn't it you ready guys
[Music]
Jesus crazy do that now yeah Jesus
Christ indeed where was that so alien
isolation to confirm if you're reading
this leaving this go cow kaali's
boogeyman's here eating everyboby
many bark boogie man's here hell they're
comin help me Mommy
eating everybody okay he messed up this
room what was he doing in here anyway
playing okay so we go down here but I
don't I don't mind I want to turn around
wait can we actually go upstairs
[Music]
oh we can oh that's good let's just go
down and see what's down there I might
just be one that will bring stuff he was
doing
probably should have saved I mean Oh
sherry right there oh well I'm Jana
hello Patsy no just awkward staring okay
that doesn't seem cutscenes or something
[ __ ] full skirt oh right
should have saved okay that's a good
thing oh stop I can hear it
keep going fast which is possible Claire
come on
[Music]
should have come upstairs
well can you hear me
clear clear you have to get up he's
playing to get us wake up wake up come
on Claire wake up wake up open your eyes
oh hello it's still not infected
sure
where's sherry sure I'm sure he's fine
do you know sherry
it's impressive displays drinks I filled
that with Sherry's mom happen to her
could they look kind of alike we have to
assess the situation who are you
I'm Claire
for see this excuse me where is she
hello word Oh Annette tell me what
happened to William I don't know who is
that the creature responsible for this
can you help me find Shari are you going
look I don't have time for 20 questions
everything's under control I need to
find share my daughter is not your
concern
yeah yeah hey scanners cool
Sherri's where did Sheri go did you not
see the resemblance woman
[Music]
the G violet virus clinical trial will
be entering its final place I assume
before G the new creature will surpass
humans is that will surpass humans is
born allow me to predict a few things
about his biology and biological
functions intelligence the subjects
intelligence will begin to drop
immediately with their linguistic
abilities disappearing within a matter
of days finally they'll lose their
capacity to reason that and their
humanity why are you making oh yeah wor
G will be a creature of pure instinct
driven only by a need to survive and
reproduce still that's not that's not
you obviously you can't give it like
rules why would you make this do due to
due to its unusually do you mean jus to
not do - hey Sami Lana Vic due to its
unusually accelerated cell division
evolution it will be highly adaptable to
any environment furthermore with its
amazing ability to prepare itself
through a regeneration it will be
extremely just got to completely come up
with any conventional small firepower
G's most remarkable feature will be its
intense desire to reproduce it will
instinctively search out humans with DNA
that closest matches its onin implant an
embryo in them
it reproduced in the man but the chances
of success are very low and it's a DNA
is not close enough of match and
underdeveloped G Kuchar will be produced
instead this is what happened I suppose
the only ones who might be a close
enough match would be any biological
children of the subject though you don't
get sherry don't impress me Jeffrey hey
hey them
hey at that hey scent eat our fragrance
no I just itched my one of my sparkles
of my so many green halves I'm doing so
well now
gun powder goodness hmm s about 60 I
don't have that one
yes
don't have the other one
we have acid rounds for it too oh this
one
so many gums
now will slaves where are you
this is a campaign for a girl or there's
a lot of campaigns so the way the
present evil is oh thanks for the
subscribe the way the present evil works
is like you play as Claire or Leon they
both have different stories so I've
already done Leon and now I'm doing
Claire sherry can you hear me
well at least mr. active dare I say dead
I'm gonna smell like [ __ ] doesn't matter
don't think I have that
but did you
tell me how to quickly change my odd
so many disgruntle exam
cable car here I wish I will be often
lose a bit mom
Oh up
so as Leon already winded we need to do
the puzzle again Shari why didn't you
stay in the house it was safe there
hey Shari I was scared
those things were everywhere and you
should have called the police that's
what we taught me I did but nobody came
in you didn't answer your phone so
sheriff I don't have time for this Jerry
Jerry I'm coming
[Music]
push you're not hardcore mr. Leaphart or
so for those that didn't know I came
here before as Liang and I've already
done this but it's slightly different
when you play oh when you play as Claire
so like things have moved around and
stuff
[Music]
Jackson Jax like and it's just trying to
save the world y'all and they'll carry
you about her daughter she should know
more than anyone that the police aren't
gonna do anything to help new it I
bloody knew it
[Music]
sure which way
huh okay Claire I've made it this far
you're almost out of the city
I've got to take care of something
before I leave but I need to tell you
something in case I don't make it this
was all umbrellas doing let the people
know I do wristband Keylong for cable
car entry
down here
housing that was important
hi did I just pass the door
[Music]
I wish I had my shotgun
I know right they're gonna get back okay
Tommy us
I feel like I need a lot of space I'm
gonna go here bye bye goodbye
you okay yeah fine onee-sama killed Jane
doesn't keys
they look like I'm kind of remembering
things oh yes so that's the room with
all the little pieces
[Music]
okay
I don't mean I don't even up
and he went in to me
why am i hearing like namib eyes
oh Jesus they're everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
I say might as well try and kill them
out
you have to come back right now I've got
good shields it's up with you stay in
doggy for me thank you was Judith
hello
okay well
[Music]
Thanks
I'm still in shock okay
like kick away kick away okay I usually
worn my housemate when I'm playing the
same but I forgot to you today so
hopefully she just
that's realized
[Music]
what are you guys saying cute - I did I
miss something what was cute monsters oh
my god yeah I thought there was at least
one down here already
before I came back here a couple of
times isn't if I can do this your way
[Music]
hello mr. bloody zombie the bishop and
the Queen but I've got the King oh but
it still worked
the Queen
you need the king
oh no that's not the king then I don't
have a king
ain't no king
should you see that you just fell down
you okay
[Music]
[Music]
no legs for you no thank you
you don't got no legs you don't have any
legs you have none legs
[Music]
[Music]
what is the spark shot the gun fires
wide metal prongs into your target
allowing you to fry it with electricity
for as long as you have their weapon
raised you can see continue to stay
focused in your target if you let the
gun send too much power over the wires
the wires will snap after one final
search ok so I fire wires into my
enemies
okay should be interesting yeah yeah you
can unlock it yes
I'm going to do this again
I need the King right now the king is
and then the queen is here
can I do this now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wish I could decapitate them with the
doors I'll be fun wait I thought that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
opening oh yeah can't bloody remember
how to do this and if I can do it now
join me for that one the king I need the
king for this one wait can I open I use
the
stop it
this one no that's the king this one in
here that one in here yeah I think we
got it and then I can come back around
this way grab you this way and then go
Ewing we can go back
cuz I love the sewers well fine now
[Music]
come back out please
right
come on
[Music]
I never got poison when I feel okay we
need to go back to find ourselves a blue
hair just being
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay don't white clown
I'll find you something find me
something well the map anywhere we'll
just go back yeah we'll just go back I
think I've got I might have one in the
storage if not the way that's gonna have
to go searching damn I never thought I
won a blue half so badly
it's alright maybe we can see us oh yeah
she's coughing I wonder if that will let
them
[Music]
all right
oh okay so too bad
movement for what we're doing
do we wait to visit oh we've already got
them
great I was like so now it's me
[Music]
[Music]
hold up
which hat is an auto-scrolling oh it's
so annoying when it does that sometimes
I don't even know why it doesn't it just
do this sometimes reloading the chart
right no it should start also slowly
again I can actually see what you guys
are saying
[Music]
yeah we're in a much better position now
let's don't forget there's one around
this [ __ ] corner
hmm yes I remember there is one more
elsewhere it's somewhere else
I remember the vicinity but I can't
remember exactly where it is so let's go
searching acid rounds here we go yeah we
did have a booth here it's good to me oh
okay well that's all right a lot of
greenhouse so
after drums and flame rounds I feel like
I want to save the flame lady yeah I
saved them for a little bit I might pick
some up we shall see
and
you don't have any bullets for that guns
and that's like pick some out baby up
gunk on here
what does gunpowder and hi grenade
gunpowder make oh I'll keep the gun on
anyway just in case
fine take it away I'm safe just give the
Diane
oh it's gotta just said save your acid
the g3 back in so maybe I'll take the
flame
it's up in the area of the sewage
treatment stop some zombies just waiting
my down
[Music]
these would not have to worry about
mister
would be annoying that if you can
actually come in here and then go
underneath the sewage
wait
does mr. X come back I have not a clue
scan to DA I mean scan to talk I mean it
looked like he died he had a big chunk
taken out of his waist but I really
would not be surprised he is a nice
sheet and he comes back with them with a
hole in
I mean Resident Evil 7 them all right
yes we feel unsafe when they just sit
there like that
[Applause]
I know I need you there because I need
the last one I wonder if it's gonna be
the same video a so last time you just
get back that way why am I going this
way we'll go back don't why
[Music]
it's not my saladna again I'm in for the
wrong things
[Music]
okay I need to go back to get my gun but
now I guess tactic is run
and keep on running
I feels like don't let her know I don't
want to look at the checkout so I can
see people like don't let her know so uh
what's down here safety please
Oh
[Music]
okay cool
we can go through yeah that's fine
kind of cleared out this room there's
just one zombie falling about we might
have to watch out popping nuts okay I'm
gonna sneeze I'll come back through they
always come back
try to get the safe he forgot about I
don't know their code to it okay let's
see if it's the same tape glare which I
watched that she's so sorry
I want to keep it because I wouldn't use
it
listen s60 and
my mommy
right now we don't have honor that one
oh we don't need these dice
so we got
wait dude I thought we have a Murphy I
thought we knew for you I said 60
high-powered rounds so like am I
fine we'll keep this anyway some
guessing will come across
I'd almost say that I want it to be a
shortcut but for the down run
okay
whatever
oh yes and that's good like now how am i
doing I'm cold
[Music]
[Applause]
trying to think of which way to go think
about the moment a damn it should put
that roll of film anything
any good stuff
yaagh much do you watch overlord anime
now I don't should I
I knew he wasn't dead I mean they're all
kind of well they're like more infected
right no I think they do die but then
they kind of come back to life
whoa look at the way he died problem
went backwards but he's still kind of on
his toes that's funny
sorry I moved him let's just see what do
two of these combined make
is that it hmm nothing what's down here
so no once I take out that chest piece
it's gonna be locked oh you sure this
kind of guys
in that case do I have more users now
I really want a shortcut I just did a
shortcut
ah wait if I go this one and then going
your right and left down I can move its
parts why do I want to do that wait s
zf4 what
they're safe around here somewhere Wow
it's making ominous noises there
hold up I'm not gonna yeah
okay now I'm ready
develop the film Jackson Jackson we
gotta be back at the police station for
that
oh the Bahji need the badge okay now I
can develop the film cuz I'm back at the
police station need the badge anyway I
think we should but at the same time so
is this back to the police station
yeah that's back to the police station I
think
oh wait I could go up there and get the
badge now just save me some time
but where are you
[Music]
now we need to do this no no take the
USB button
nice
now what is
get this way
are we gonna have a big encounter wait
now this is where we first met Shari
right we gonna get back backtrack
backtrack everyone loves the backtrack
nobody likes it back try by Martin thank
you for coming
Merriman Martin
[Music]
I think as a bad choice don't remember
if I pass there again oh oh go back I
don't remember near thee again
[Music]
okay cool
sobbing Lana bik's as I don't need
anything that's good to know
Oh
this way
what about the film I can't do that yeah
I'm in the wrong place camping now let's
try and figure out which one
okay some of them have
I come from anyway so she keeps Alan
let's read
I need this the Rick's next to the night
but not facing the Queen the King isn't
next to the Queen but facing the night
it's not next to the Queen
but it's facing that night
well the Knights yes it's gotta be here
right at the end and the knight aimed
where the case marking says outdoors hmm
Brooks next to the night
but it is on the end
and not facing the Queen
next there might not face my dream
maybe they're the opposite ways Oh No
and it is on the end facing the night
right at the end
mess the night is over here
maybe so maybe they're switched yeah
and then the king is facing the night on
the end but it's not next to the Queen
rooks next to the night but not facing
the green
oh wait that's not the green
[Music]
that was a little bit gangster
or should I just take out ours wait to
find anyone
hey yes man how are you saying thanks
for asking Christian all right
I'm being like tired it's been a really
long week but in a really good way but I
don't know I've got like I've got this
new job I can't believe it's not even
been three months
yeah but I'm just doing so much and
learning so much it's really good though
we I had to show off like all my work to
the big directors because this is my
first ever like proper job in the games
industry so I was a bit like but well
and then I quickly got up and showed the
studio like what I've been working on
I'm just I'm exactly like I am they're
like I am here so I'm just like hey ya
made this video lolwut so derpy but it
were good it went good but it has left
me so tired today like I've been
thinking about it recently it's like I I
do love this job I'm so happy I'm here
but it's making me so tired to do all my
other stuff and I wish I could do it
more but I'm thinking that
the more I get used to this job and the
more I like because I am learning so
much every day I think I'll find it
easier and then I'll have more time I've
just got to let myself settle into it
cuz I'm I'm living in a new place as
well which kind of helps us streaming
because I don't know anyone so I don't
really have an excuse not sister even
but anyway that's ramble how are you
power must be out
give me all
yeah
thanks tanners
unchristian
go to the safe okay that makes sense
I'll go to the same
[Music]
then he please not
Jesus Christ come on this way sir
okay just [ __ ] run to the phone
stop it
Celes why was that so much easy to keep
him there when I was Leon
[Music]
[Music]
right
come on
dude I hadn't even press on
time for an encore yeah
right in your eye
[Music]
nerve not funny
like a monkey honor something has
something no how does that Sunday
[Music]
[Music]
I mean sure
because I got a surprise for you there's
a bee on the floor
[Music]
[Music]
come on Brisbane please hurry
time for an encore the token of these
stone is coming to say that just stay
down
thank you
my gonna see it's all right [ __ ] me I'm
play me the weapon oh my god did you
just blink did you actually just blink
and that's why I didn't hit you in the
eye
[Music]
look oh my god go the crane bite have I
got a surprise for you yes yes just
please don't do it up
[Music]
what am I looking for
[Music]
he blinks in your mr. sherry so annoying
this is taking forever
yes actually is
a meme has just been uploaded in the
discord did you know we have a discord
if it's not in the description I'll put
it in the chat layin everybody one here
is on the discord I think you can yeah
you can invite people so feel free to
oh she actually cares ma'am
sherry clear
sherry are you all right what are you
doing when actually they actually help
did mate with her Sherry's been
implanted she can't be saved [ __ ]
kidding me you're her mother get in here
you don't understand
William is still out there and if I
don't stop him this conversation is over
wait wait I can treat her in my lab it's
not far away she could treat her and she
was late she's just gonna leave her
oh there's not enough time millions of
lives are at stake
sherry mommy loves you sweetie thank you
for this crappy goodbye but I'm so
annoyed
are you [ __ ] kidding me sure don't
worry I'll get you whatever you need
okay because I care
Oh best big sister that there ever was
so I don't know where I'm going
guess it's nothing in there said her
labs not far
wait that cable car
freaking zombie bear - a lion you're
gonna be fine
maybe because she's hot [ __ ] they'll
leave us alone now oh he's gone
we're almost there she made this safe
guys can I actually open it now I don't
think I can then trap with anything what
I've got sherry now sorry oh that yes
yes good and I don't say y'all like a
hillbilly ass man
here okay I just hold on sherry okay
you're gonna be just fine okay
mmm better check everything there's no
turning back
okay so this is when we go back to the
safe when I thought zombie just randomly
magically appears no no he's gone for
good good good flat didn't one of us
once we get down there there's India
some stuff anyways he said oh yes to
twelve eight five six seven eight nine
ten
oh my gosh that's gonna help okay thanks
guys
oh it's ins yeah now I can use those
bullets without em guessing
oh I really don't want to go all the way
back just to do the left a picture that
I've already seen when I was Leon so I
think I'm just gonna leave it Jack's a
jack sorry
it'll just be a clue to like a safe or
something and I will have seen it when I
was Leon
[Music]
I'll save now anyway just Paul
all right
okay we are going and down we defend
this tram is vamper nest
Jumma exit until the final destination
she can feel it inside are you okay
while she's so cute in our duel jacket
brother gave it to me
you know what's supposed to be lucky
I don't know what I'd do without you
are you kidding me you were doing just
fine without me I came along and got you
all sorts of trouble
I have something here's
really why not so pretty it's a mom with
something right
my birthday last year
all I really wanted was for her to be
home more I know it seems like your mom
Hey sure
yeah hang in there okay No
[Music]
it's okay I've got you we gotta hurry up
I'm getting you treatment
just hold on sherry it's okay
- yes enjoy your visit
ok alright
know what huh
there's got to be something here
antiviral agent that's it that's gotta
be it hmm hey hey sherry I gotta go you
stay right here though okay I'll be back
soon I promise
got a brass band um I might I might
leave that here actually yeah see it all
this um yeah I think I'm gonna leave I
yeah cuz I've got some stuff to do for
the EP
I'm actually I'm buying all the CDs and
stuff today so it's a thing it's
happening I want to do another edit of
the video with the music video to
Switzer